ça fait un an et demi qu'un hélicoptère
vole sur Mars il était transporté par
persévérance le rover qui a atterri sur
Mars en 2021 ça a pris deux semaines
pour le déployer et tester les hélices
mais finalement le 19 avril il décolle
pendant 39 secondes c'est la première
fois de l'histoire qu'on fait voler un
véhicule sur une autre planète le
challenge était fou la gravité est plus
faible sur Mars que sur terre mais
l'atmosphère est aussi cent fois moins
dense pour réussir à le soulever ces
énormes hélices tournent cinq fois plus
vite que nos hélicoptères terrestres ces
panneaux solaires doivent lui permettre
de voler mais aussi de se chauffer la
nuit pour l'empêcher de geler et il doit
être indépendant vu qu'on ne peut pas le
contrôler en direct comme un drone pour
célébrer l’exploit il y a un morceau du
tout premier avion accroché de sous
depuis son arrivée il décolle 38 fois
pour un total de 58 minutes passées dans
les airs et oui